donc ils étaient dix neuf heures environ
et je sortais de ma voiture et je
regarde dans le ciel et qu'est ce que je
vois j'ai l'impression que c'était des
avions qui est en manoeuvre donc il
dépeint en triangle et ce qui m'étonnait
pourtant c'est que j'ai entendu aucun
bruit dont je me suis dit ou alors il
faut la très haute altitude mais alors
je les verrai pas donc ça ne paraissait
pas logique et après je suis l'on
accepte des étoiles filantes mais
combien y avait presque une dizaine de
10 kms et social
j'ai fais un voeu et puis je me suis dit
on verra bien j'ai pensé d'abord qu'il
s'agissait effectivement de fusée du
volant de choses de ce genre qui était
lancé m'a ensuite que j'ai mis comme
j'ai vu que ça dirigeait donc vers le
zénith c'était oui j'étais relativement
surpris hier c'était un spectacle
relativement très très beau voilà tout
ce que tout ce que je me dépense et des
ovnis non j'ai reçus à partir de 19h10
quelques coups de téléphone de personne
ne m'a plan de différents villages
avoisinants me demandant si j'étais si
j'avais connaissance d'un phénomène
bizarre verticale ces personnes signalé
avoir vu un objet lumineux qui passait
dans le ciel un objet de forme ronde
assez important qui se déplaçait
lentement de l'ouest vers l'est avec une
gerbe d'étincelles à l'arrière même si
les radars n'ont rien détecté c'est
désormais sur le ciel de strasbourg a
été hier soir le théâtre d'un phénomène
insolite une apparition de quelques
instants qui devrait trouver une
explication naturelle
peut-être par la présence de nombreux
satellites c'est tout à fait plausible
que à un des nombreux satellites sont
décomposées que un morceau ce choix
décomposé en plusieurs parcelles et que
nous ayons vu ça ou bien une autre
explication peut-être y at-il eu à un
météorite assez épais assez gros qui
serait qu'il se désintégrer assez bas
déjà dans la peau sphère badin très
haute atmosphère et là aussi les
différents morceaux du les compositions
que nous aurions pu voir peut-être dès
aujourd'hui l'observatoire de munich
confirment l'hypothèse d'une météorite
qui aurait explosé
en entrant dans l'atmosphère quant au
centre national d'études spatiales il
n'a pas encore donné ses conclusions